dans quels étaient toujours en cours
concernant les éventuelles défaillances
qui ont provoqué la mort de plusieurs
des missiles essentielle après l'échec
d'une opération qui avait coûté la vie à
douze de nos delhi 6
commandant james reece de l'unité alfa
pouvez vous faire le compte rendu de la
mission il savait conviendrait d'après
le fichier audio vous avez coupé la com
au bout de quatre kilomètres à
l'intérieur pourquoi
c'est pas ce qui s'est passé
tu vois bien ça va
des maux de tête un sentiment
paranoïaque et des troubles de la
mémoire
on va s'en sortir tu verras
tu veux me raconter ce qui s'est passé
on nous a donné une fausse info sur cani
on a été piégé
si vraiment j'ai raison je sais qu'il
faut réagir je veux des noms si un lien
avec vous et vos hommes je le trouverai
les réponses ou du sang
du sang
oui james reece c'est vrai que votre
site est un délit s'il est poursuivi par
pas mal d'emplois auraient donc pour
l'instant mais là en veilleuse dont
douze de mes hommes rentrent au pays
dans un cercueil
c'est personnel
vous avez préféré jouer à la guerre
maintenant vous êtes sur le champ de
bataille
le mal est partout dans ce monde un
point que tu n'imagine même pas
gibbs qui ta maison avec l'uci tout de
suite
je vous le répète repas
ne soyez jamais son analyste